so I pick Microsoft Excel fun I take
things that would traditionally be
boring and dry but are things that
people need to know and then Infuse them
with fun and creativity so that it's
actually something entertaining and
you're actually paying attention so then
you learn the skills if you don't like
dancing don't dance that for me when
creating my business I was just pulling
in things that are authentic to me and I
was like I love to help people I love
Excel and I love to dance and how can I
put those three things that I love in a
video so really it's a matter of finding
what lights you up and what you actually
love and infusing that into the content